all right uh more from the daily wire
Republican president candidate president
presidential candidate and former vice
president Mike Pence clash with Tucker
Carlson during a combative interview on
Friday in Iowa Pence's interview at the
family Leadership Summit focused on the
war in Ukraine his beliefs about what
happened during January 6 riot at the
U.S Capitol and his views on the 2020
presidential election uh this entire
Summit was uh was fascinating tuck
Carlson did a brilliant job of um
questioning everyone who showed up and
all the major presidential candidates
showed up except for Donald Trump he
didn't come
but um
Tucker Carlson kind of shows what it
means to to
like even though it's no surprise it's
no secret he's a conservative and so he
agrees
well you would think he agrees
fundamentally with most of these people
or at least they they should have much
in common philosophically
although when it comes to people like
Pence and Nikki Haley there's there's
not much in common there
um
but in spite of that
you can still press someone and have a
very revealing conversation in fact
if you can
you know if you have some common ground
it becomes a it can become a much more
probing and um compelling interview uh
because now you're getting into more of
like the specific details
and this is what happened with this and
here's the one clip this is specifically
the conversation about Ukraine
and um we'll play the whole interview
some of this is being taken out of
context we'll play the we'll play the
whole clip here and then we'll talk
about it here it is
we've been telling them we'll train
their F-16 Pilots but now they're saying
maybe January we'll let somebody
transfer some Jets I'm sorry Mr vice
president have you I know you're running
for president
you are direct you are distressed that
the ukrainians don't have enough
American tanks every city in the United
States has become much worse over the
past three years drive around there's
not one city that's gotten better in the
United States and it's visible our
economy has degraded the suicide rate
has jumped public filth and disorder and
crime have exponentially increased and
yet your concern is that the ukrainians
a country most people can't find on a
map who've received tens of billions of
U.S tax dollars don't have enough tanks
I think it's a fair question to ask like
where's the concern for the United
States in that well it's not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country's in
a lot of trouble
I think Joe Biden has weakened America
at home and abroad
and as president of the United States
we're going to restore Law and Order in
our cities we're going to secure our
border we're going to get this economy
moving again and we're going to make
sure that we have men and women on our
Courts at every level that will stand
for the right to life and defend all the
god-given Liberties enshrined in our
constitution
anybody that says that we can't be the
leader of the Free World and solve our
problems at home has a pretty small view
of the greatest nation on Earth we can
do both and as president of the United
States we will secure our border we will
support our military we will Revive Our
economy and stand by our values and we
will also lead the world for Freedom
under my Administration
okay so I will say that Pence's critics
of which I am one have um
intentionally taken this clip out of
context which is
which is unfortunate for a number of
reasons
namely it's it's not necessary there's
plenty there to criticize
but it's the taken out of context into
really cheap and manipulative way and
they all know what they're doing he said
that's not my concern and what you see
some of his Critics on Twitter claiming
is that is that he was saying that the
United States isn't his concern
but obviously he didn't say that he's
not going to say even if he thought that
he's not going to say that
he was trying to say that the stuff
about Ukraine isn't really his concern
okay that Ukraine is not his concern he
was pushing back on that critique from
Tucker his wording was awkward his
timing was awkward but
come on that's obviously what he was
trying to convey as central banks in
countries like China India and Australia
began looking to transition to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
a digital currency the government could
track every single purchase you make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze or seize part or all of your
money Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold you can do that with
the help of Birch gold and they are who
I buy my gold from so do thousands of
other concern Savers Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira 401K
into an IRA in gold and you don't pay a
penny out of pocket
when currencies failed gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
really have think about that so I got to
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold as an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers you can find out why by
texting Walsh to 989-898 and get your
free info kit on gold of a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it'll
be nice to have some gold to depend on
again text Walsh to
989898 you know I love anything made
with top of the line quality for Meats
that's good ranchers the only thing
missing is a pork box you know it's the
only thing they didn't have it was the
only hole in in the whole plan well if
you ask for it they will deliver good
ranchers has just launched their Prime
pork 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and much more
plus right now you'll get 30 off with my
code Walsh at goodrancers.com on their
site you can explore their All-American
cuts of prime pork Prime Beef and better
than organic chicken options as well if
you've tried their beef and chicken
before then you know how amazing it is
you have to try this Prime pork at least
once trust me they've got genuinely
great products and top tier customer
service so what are you waiting for
enjoy real meat and real service today
with good ranchers visit
goodranchers.com use my code Walsh for
30 off any box that's promo code Walsh
at goodrancers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered
with that said Tucker's point is
entirely correct Ukraine is simply
not something that should be on our list
of concerns at all it shouldn't make our
list of priorities period
it's not on the list
and uh those like Mike Pence and Nikki
Haley and the rest of the establishment
Republicans and Democrats as well
who think the United States should
continue to be involved in Ukraine
should even get more involved
potentially
you know they've had well over a year
now to explain
why this should matter to American
families
okay why should it matter to American
families it it just an average American
citizen who gets up in the morning and
has kids as a family to feed all the
things that they're thinking about and
worried about
um
why should this be on the list
okay why would an average American spend
any time during the day worried about
what happens with Ukraine
how does it affect us
and they've had a year
well over a year to make that case and
to explain
and they haven't been able to do it like
the best they can do is say well it's
it's all about freedom and the
principles of freedom
which first of all
um Ukraine and its corrupt government
cares as much about freedom and
democracy as Putin does
and second
what does the freedom of Ukraine like
even if this was about freedom
panzilinski was some sort of freedom
fighter it's a virtuous freedom fighter
still
how does that affect us how does it
impact us whether Ukraine is free or not
whether Ukraine is in its own uh control
under its own control under the control
of Russia how does that affect us how
does that impact us
they haven't been able to make that case
they haven't been able to connect those
dots uh because because you can't
and they know they can't
and that's what really matters there
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast